bismillah humble assalamu alaikum peace
be with you I'm a dear host you're
watching a Deen show every week we're
here trying to enlighten the minds
lighting the hearts to a whole new
understanding you're away from the rated
movies you're away from all the
distractions and all the things many of
them which are no benefit there's much
benefit in watching this program because
it's something that when you implement
it it's going to change your life for
what for the better there are many
issues that we cover the issue that
we're going to be talking about today
because when you're on your way to
investigate what is the purpose of life
why am I here in this life I'm gonna die
and where do I go from there
you know what is there an ultimate truth
there's so many religions out there how
do we know how do we decipher what is
the way of life that was revealed from
the creator of the heavens and earth how
do we know what so many of them so we're
gonna give you a crash course on many of
the world religions that are out there
so then you can be the judge for
yourself what makes most sense and what
provides the most evidence and proof
that it is indeed from the one creator
who created this whole universe and
everything in it so then you can live
that way of life that he revealed for
you to live and then at the end you can
avoid the Hellfire and you can be
admitted to Paradise and that's what
we're all striving for sit tight we'll
be right back here on the Deen show
this is the thesis but angel
and I'm here with the president of the I
r e F brother Imran Salaam alaikum
Malika most Salaam when I'm at the Labor
Code how are you hamdulillah I'm fine
brother how about you alhamdulillah we
said something in Arabic so the people
out there they don't have to take an
Arabic class what do we just say we said
may the peace be unto you that is what
you addressed me and then I said may the
peace be unto you too
and then I said you asked me how are you
I said alhamdulillah meaning all the
presence of Allah subhana Allah the
Cherisher and sustainer of the universe
that is what I said by saying
alhamdulillah now someone says you know
what there they go worshiping a moon God
Oh what are you gonna say now so I Alya
inshallah see this is one of the biggest
biggest illogical statement anybody can
give one ayat of the Quran just one ayat
in the Quran is enough to throw this
allegation verbatim word of God yeah
this is the verbatim word of allah
subhanaw taala hundred persons were by
the will of Allah you see Allah says in
surah number forty one generally surah
is taken as chapter surah number
forty-one ayat number thirty-seven Allah
says do not prostrate yourself to the
Sun and the moon
do not make sajda to the Sun and the
moon neither worship them but prostrate
to your true God allah subhanaw taala
and worship Him alone the one who
created both of them that is very close
case God Jesus [ __ ] ah so you praise you
start we started out crazy with the one
God the same God Jesus worship the same
God Noah Abraham all the messengers got
word that one god that's the guy we were
talking about
now tell us there's a lot of for many
people they say confusion out there I
don't want to follow any organ
religions you know and you know they put
Islam in the buffet and they think it's
all man-made we know that man has
changed a lot of the religions to suit
the times
Islam is indeed how it was revealed we
have it today tamper free tamper proof
it's from the divine but just to give
people some kind of a taste from a lot
of the world religions out there at
crash course because many people don't
know about them let's start off because
Islam encourages that we do reflect
because when we see the in consistencies
the contradictions in the man-made
religions will see that this is indeed
will appreciate its Lomb even more so
talk to us give us a little bit of a
closer I would like to begin my session
again al-hamdu lillahi rabbil alameen wa
sallahu wa salam ala rasulina cream what
Ali he was happy at my in all praises
are due to Allah subhana Allah alone may
the peace and salutations of Allah be
upon prophet muhammed sallalahu salam
his family and his male and female
companions the Sahaba Karamazov louder
and much mein although B'Elanna sat on
the regime in Edina in the lion Islam
also be like me Shaitan regime well my
battery Harun islami dinan following
yoke Balaam I knew what in are here at
Aminu hacer en rubbish Ronny's everybody
is silly hungry one who looked ottoman
asani of how holy this last part is the
dua that I always read because it's a
wonderful toy it's a beautiful dua of
moosa alaih-is-salaam when he made
before giving the Dawa of Islam to feel
on you Syria has for a number 20 I had
number 25 26 27 and 28 so moosa resume
dad wine said o my lord expand my breast
for me make me courageous give me more
knowledge for your Siddeley humbly and
make my task easy for me
voila that'll mean l-'ihsani remove any
obstruction or impediment from my speech
you holy and open their mind to
understand what i speak so that is a do
I always make see there are so many
religions today on the face of the earth
there is about six billion human
population approximately on the face of
the earth and of these six billion 2.3
billion are those people who claim
themselves to be Christians
and 1.2 billion are those who claim
themselves as Muslims so more than half
of the world population belongs to 2 of
these major religions either one or the
other Christian Christian or most
Muslims yes more than 50% of the human
population belongs to two of these major
religions the others
the third one goes Hinduism I come from
India from Hyderabad and my country
India is the second largest populated
populated country in the world after
China and our population has eighty
percent of those people who call
themselves as Hindus and then you have
Buddhists the fourth largest group of
the world religion is Buddhists then you
have other groups like the Jews the Jews
of course they belong to a religion
which is Semitic which is very popular
but their number is very few compared to
these major numbered religions based on
the followers let me check the history
of these religions you'll be surprised
none of these religions have a divine
origin except Islam none of them none of
them both right yeah that's a very bold
statement and it's backed by evidences
you're gonna give their ever inshallah
all right you see as I told I come from
a country called India back in India
Hinduism is considered to be the major
most religion of the world if you trace
the word Hindu or Hinduism in any of the
religious scriptures of the Hindus
whether you take the Vedas considered by
them to be the Shruti the revealed Word
of God the hindus called vedas primarily
for vedas paraguay the other way they do
within the sun is they call it the
revelation of god if you read these
scriptures the word hindu or Hinduism
does not come they for one single time
if you read the other books of Hinduism
the Puranas the Upanishads the Arron
yuccas the et Havas like the Mahabharata
and the Ramayana what are these books
you just you just mentioned the opening
shots are the interpretations of these
revealed books so you have Hinduism as
the religion and the other are the
Hindus they claim that Hinduism is a
religion and they believe these
scriptures to be their religious
scriptures that's their constitution
their guideline
the guidelines for Hinduism the primary
source for Hinduism are the Vedas and
all other books are also considered as
religious books for Hinduism you read
all of them the word Hindu and Hinduism
does not occur for one single time in
any of these books at all at all not
forcing the time that these are facts
again that we're given we're gonna take
a break we have the break up second and
we'll be right back shush shush shush
thank you say we right back here on the
Dean show and if we're gonna worship
something I figured I might as well
worship the creator instead of any of
the creations now in upon investigating
the religions I remember find another
meaning of what Islam is what most
limits those who surrender their self to
cut is a Muslim those who surrender
submit to God God's will that is Islam
was pure it was just you just pray to
God you create when outside everything
looks good you see the hundred thousand
dollar cars you see a lot of diamonds
you see a lot of females and they think
that this is you know this is a life
this is this is like no paradise right
here
with this Milan job to go into someone's
heart to change the heartbeat your job
is to topi what the truth is and then
the alley over there is while we're
sitting here while I'm sitting here
constantly paying for the disease to
kill was free
back here in the DS show with the
president of the Islamic research
education vocational foundation basic
research and Educational Foundation and
brother refers prefers that I don't call
him shake or move dear mallanna
he wants to be called brother yeah and
I'm really people respect that and I
respect that you're here with us and
you're doing this wonderful work and
we're here to benefit from your
knowledge so tell us sheikh can you tell
brother mark can you please tell us the
as you were going the the or hinduism
randomizing now you see this is one
thing the first thing is the word Hindu
and Hinduism does not occur in their
religious scripture for a single time
apart from that if you try to find out
from they did this word Hindu and
Hinduism come so you will know that
encyclopedia of religion and ethics
published from the New York in the year
1699 on page number 699 of the book it
mentions that the word Hindu was used by
the Muslims after their Advent in India
the Hindus might disagree to this they
might say we don't believe in
encyclopedia religion and ethics so we
could them another important source and
the prominent source that is the
Encyclopedia Britannica the new edition
volume number 20 page number 581 it says
the word Hindu was coined by the British
when they were ruling India in the year
1800 and 32 refer to the people living
beyond Indus River and that included the
Muslims the sex the Christians and all
others living beyond industry were
industry were falls into the north part
of India anybody living beyond that
whatever does Hindus again the Hindus
might say we don't believe this we don't
want to follow it so we code them
another prominent source that is pending
Jawaharlal Nehru Pandit Jawaharlal Nehru
was a born Brahmin Brahman in the hindu
religion is considered to be the topmost
caste it's a cast that is responsible to
give the teachings to give the
injunctions about hinduism to the
remaining followers
Nehru was a pure Brahmin a born Kashmiri
Bremen and he wrote a beautiful book
entitled discovery of India it's very
popular back in India in the 1983
edition of that book published from New
Delhi on page number 72 to 74 when you
read he mentions that the word Hindu was
used for the first time in an eighth
century Christian era tantric book and
there it was not used religiously but
was used to refer to a group of people
living geographically beyond Indus River
then if you read a book written by one
of the greatest reformers of Hinduism
according to the Hindus that is Swami
Vivekananda
he was the first Hindu to be invited by
the American government and he gave a
talk in the American Senate in a
conference and he is very popular back
in India and Swami Vivekananda in one of
his book house his name Swami
Vivekananda's swabbies awake a manga
Swami Vivekananda ok I'm a master of go
ahead please yeah so Swami Vivekananda
in his book essentials of Hinduism he
mentions in that book on page number six
and seven he says it is a misnomer to
refer as as Hindus to misnomer it's a
misnomer that is what he says the
reformer of Hinduism he says Hinduism is
a misnomer to us instead we shall be
referred as Veda and pissed meaning
people who believe and follow the Vedas
adds the word of God you look at this it
is very clear and obvious that the word
Hindu and Hinduism are not divine terms
they are a term given to any person any
Tom Dick and Harry living beyond Indus
River as a Muslim a bond Indian Muslim I
have I was born in Hyderabad city of
India so I am a Hindu Muslim I am Muslim
by my faith and Hindus geographically
because I live burned industry well if
you translate this complete statement
into English it would be I am an Indian
Muslim that is what it would mean
so Hinduism is not a religion as such
and there is no one particular
lawbook that can guide the entire hindus
for example if you meet any Christian
and ask what is your law book he would
immediately defer my my book is the
Bible
if you meet a Jew he would say my book
is the Tanakh or he might refer to the
Torah
if you meet a Muslim unanimously entire
Muslim community irrespective of any
difference of opinion into any subject
of Islam unanimously all Muslims on the
face of the earth agree that Quran is
the religious book as well as the no
book for them to follow in their life
but if you meet a Hindu it's very
difficult to know which is the law book
they divided into so many groups
according to a theory
they worship about 330 million gods and
goddesses they worship this many 330
million gods and goddesses gods and
goddesses yeah and that would mean you
would have to give them 330 million
different names to call them by a
religion which was impossible to happen
what's that we know in Islam the the
main fundament the whole thing is based
on pure monotheism where should be the
Creator Nadi's Christian only
worshipping God what is the main
teaching of the Hinduism
it's a polity its religion their worship
different deities they do not have a one
single perfect concept of the Almighty
God they do not have it though though
the Hindu scriptures command the Hindus
not to worship the idols not to worship
the images of God if you read the
primary Vedas if you read regrade book
number one hymn number 64 verse number
one and 64 one and forty six it clearly
mentions to them it says that the
learned made men of Hindus they call the
only one God by various names
meaning the God is one called by various
names that is what there is religious
scripture tell them if you read the yadu
wave check number 32 verse number three
it says not the sphere pratima
Asti it's a Sanskrit quotation its
Sanskrit is the language in which the
Vedas were written according to them it
says not the SIA pratima Asti which
would mean of him there is no image
meaning the God's image cannot be made
if you read the same you do read chap
number 40 verse number 9 it says and
no Commission TSM butum opacity which
means those who worship the natural
things like the Sun the Moon the Stars
the trees the snakes the elephants
whoever worship the natural things they
are in darkness and it continues to see
their own book says yeah and it
continues to say it doesn't stop there
it continues it says the people who
worship things made by their hands are
in greater darkness amazing amazing if
you read the sweetest sweetest without
punishment chap number four verse number
nineteen it again really it's not a
pretty masti of him there is no image if
you read the Creed of Hinduism ridges in
the brahma sutra it says it come brah
look you're nasty Mahan a snake engine
it Cumbre hum it come one it's a script
reference again it come one it come
Brahm one creator do cure second nasty
is not this one creator second is not
there Mena's taking shield not there at
all in the least bit if you look at
these references the Hindus have been
commanded to worship only one God
without making an image without making a
form of did God but unfortunately there
are modern-day practicing Hindus they
worship the God by making so many images
and how many according to the theory
it's 330 million gods and goddesses and
when you meet them they're so confused
so confused that they do not exactly
read the conclusion they asked to refer
to the learn Edmund you go to the
learned men then you go to the learn it
men
the landed men would say it's the art
Minds the Paramatma is the Bhagwan but
what exactly are you concluding about
God it is not there so it's not a divine
religion it's a pure man-made religion
we have so many more recover because
we're almost you know we're short on
time what would be the next one that you
want to talk to us about the net we
covered Hinduism you gave the evidences
proves yeah I would I would definitely
like to speak a little bit on Judaism
and Christianity that's very important
then final Islam yeah so Judaism is of
course popular religion it's it might
not be a major religion in the terms of
the number of adherents to it because it
does not have the policy or the
philosophy of propagating the religion
of proselytizing the religion
so they are limited in number but of
course they are a popular religion of
the world and of course very close to
both the Muslims and the Christians they
are closed on the basis of al Qaeda that
is the belief that we have about
Almighty God and other things there are
so many similarities between these three
popular religions of the world that is
Judaism Christianity and Islam and I
would definitely like to speak on these
three religions inshallah maybe after
the break at the approaching the break
we're gonna take a break and right back
with more here around the Deen show no
problem you can take my daughter to
dinner you and my daughter and me have a
good time you should have a good time
wise though Islam is the fastest growing
religion in the world and most of the
converts are women not men they see that
the rules of Islam instead of
constraining them the rules set them
free
I am not afraid to stand alone I am Not
Afraid
back here in the Dean show and
we were talking about Hinduism you
covered that covered the core teachings
and prove that it doesn't come from the
divine but in there it does have the
call to only worship one guy without any
images without any carving from your own
hand statues only worship the Creator us
with islam teaches we're moving along to
judaism and christianity please go ahead
see the world religions have been
broadly categorized as semitic and non
symmetric religions semitic religions
basically there are three major or
popular religions in the semitic
religions semitic religions are said to
be the religions followed by the
descendants of Shem and Shem according
to the Bible is supposed to be one of
the sons of Noah may peace be upon him
the commonality between the Semitic
religions all these three Semitic
religions Judaism Christianity and Islam
is all these three religions claim to be
monotheistic all these three religions
believe that God does not incarnate all
these three religions basically brief
that God sent prophets on earth to guide
the people at different times all the
three religions commonly believed that
the first human being was not evolved
but created by the Almighty God allah
subhanaw taala
and that was adamant peace be upon him
in the Quran is referred as adam
alayhis-salam
and his wife hawala salam referred in
the Oddie's and in the bible - you
mentioned the three judaism christianity
is yeah these are the somatic oh yeah
these are totally symmetric religions
believing these things to be common now
coming to the history but if you see the
history again judaism does not occur as
a term given by the almighty god for the
followers of the said concepts that we
have today in the religion of Jews
so you're saying that the creator of the
heavens energy you're gonna back this up
he didn't say okay I'm calling your Jews
or Jews or your concept God knowing this
no absolutely not
God didn't term it perfect in fact if
you read the entire panic yes come on
the Torah the Navy a man decay to him
he is considered to be the religious
books of the Jews were today again the
tonic tonic tonic is a compilation of
three basic books of the Torah which are
the first five books of the Holy Bible
of the crystals two of the Old Testament
Genesis Exodus Leviticus numbers and
tirana me the first fine the first five
books the Pentateuch which is popularly
regarded as I go by this yeah they they
do refer it as the Torah given to moosa
alaih-is-salaam but chris's agree with
them on this work and apart from that
the jews believed in navy in and Ketu
him navy in are the books of the
prophets k to him are the books of the
historians and all these three have been
compiled together in the form of Tanith
that is what they refer to their Holy
Scripture apart from that you have the
Talmud and the Mishnah yeah these are
other interpretations of the Oral Torah
yes when you read all of them there is
not a single place where it is mentioned
that the God referred to them as Jews or
the concept of their belief as Judaism
in fact in the Bible they have been
referred as the children of Israel
children of Israel yeah that in the
Quran - we know as bani israel the
children of israel and israel according
to the book of Genesis chapter 32 verse
number 24 to 30 is a name given as a
title to Jacob the son of is hostile
s-salam the second son of ibraheem
alehissalaam abraham may peace be upon
him isaac was the second son Ishmael
Ismail and s-salam was the first son and
if you read the book of Genesis cap
number 32 verse number 24 - verse number
30 Dale Jacob he has a wrestling he
wrestles with the Almighty God or the
angels of God this in the Bible this is
the Bible book of Genesis chapter number
22 was about 84 - verse number 30 when
you read it and he was so strong that
God could not overpower him or the angel
of God could not overpower him so after
that before leaving he was said from now
on you shall not be referred as Jacob
anymore
instead you shall be called Israel
Israel is a heavy world
el means God Ezra means the servant
Israel the servant of God the servant of
the Cherisher in Arabic it is Abdullah
so did this was a term given to term
given to him he had several children he
had 12 children and they were called the
bani israel the children of israel and
that is what the term carries on in the
entire Bible the word Judaism does not
therefore a single time believe me as
long as musa alehsalaam live lived on
the earth moses may peace be upon him as
long as he lived his death is mentioned
in the book of deuteronomy chat number
34 till then he never heard the term
Judaism Moses never ever never no no
never who or he no no absolutely not
absolutely not he never heard this term
Giudice it was it was the children of
Israel gotcha
that is how it was and the theory about
the word Jew being coin is amazing
according to a theory it's based on the
kingdom of Judah one of the children of
Isaac one of the twelve tribes of the
Bani Israel the kingdom of Judah it is
from this Judah that the term came but
according to another theory it comes
from the book of Genesis chapter number
37 verse number 6 to verse number 30
where a prophet by the name Judah he has
illegal sexual intercourse with his own
daughter in law and he begets children
from her but still he is revered living
in a place called Judea so the people
who revealed him were the Jews and the
concept they followed was Judaism this
is another theory but the exact history
of the term is unknown officially today
officially today the word Jew is
referred to any person who practices
Judaism and who believes in the Torah or
the Tanakh or the Talmud and the Mishnah
that is how it would go tree coming to
Christianity again yeah so we got this
other way you show that it wasn't it's
not a divine you don't give him it's not
it's not our tongue appointed by the
Almighty God let's go to Christianity
Christianity again wonderful if you read
the entire Holy Bible the Catholic Bible
the Protestant Bible the by but it's 76
books the Bible with 73 books the Bible
with 66 books in the Bible with 87 books
the Bible with 81 books you read any
Bible of the world you read all the
Bible's of the world the word
Christianity does not utter for one
single time it has got a cup one single
time the word Christian occurs three
times in the Bible and those three times
the word occurs in the
bible is used only after the Ascension
of Jesus Christ may peace be upon him as
long as Jesus Christ my peace be upon
him lived on this earth he never heard
that Tom Christ he never heard that
unchristian
he never heard the term Christianity he
never heard it if you read the Bible the
New Testament in the book of Acts
chapter number 11 verse number 26 in the
book of Acts chapter 26 verse number 28
and in the first Peter chapter number 4
verse number 16 the word Christian is
used and st. Paul he after teaching his
disciples for one year at a place called
Antioch he called his disciples and said
ye are Christians from now this term is
not a divine term coming to Islam it's
the only religion on the face of the
earth where allah subhanaw taala gave a
term to the concept allah said in Adina
in the LA hill Islam the only way of
life for you is Islam I began my talk by
reciting that add from surah al-e-imran
surah number three at number 19 I
recited another ayat from surah al-imran
surah number 3 at number 85 what my
apparel islami dinan falaya palamino
wahoooo finish here at amin al-husseini
whoever will come with any concept of
life any way of life except Islam in
hereafter it will never be accepted from
him or her and they shall be the losers
in here after the term Islam has been
given to this concept believe means we
meet Adam may peace be upon him on the
day of judgment if you meet Moses my
peace be upon him on the day of judgment
if you meet Jesus Christ my peace be
upon him on the day of judgment and if
we ask them what was your concept of
life they would say our concept of life
was to submit our well peacefully to the
will of Almighty God who sent us and
this statement in English to submit our
will peacefully surrender our will
peacefully to the will of Almighty God
is nothing but the way of Islam
that's Islam that's islam word Islam
means the submission of your will
peacefully to the will of Almighty God
that is what every prophet of Godhead so
there were Muslims all of them were
Muslims any man or woman who submit
their will to the will of God
we are Muslims because we have agreed to
submit our will to the will of God the
glorious quran the holy quran al quran
al-karim we have promised to submit our
will there therefore we are muslims by
doing that this is amazing so you prove
that these religions did not have that
coming from the divine it was something
of a geographical location as in
hinduism true and one theory hi there a
viren's
yeah on a geographical location nothing
more than that Christianity after Christ
Judaism after Judah or the other theory
that was there but God Almighty didn't
authorize this but he did authorize
submission Islam submission to the one
God and this is what all the prophets
did it makes sense it makes a lot of
sense true true and that is what Allah
says in Surat surah number thirteen at
number seven sorry bunnies Soren Soren
16 mo 36 sorry Fatima 35 at number 24
that we sent prophets to all the
communities on earth to guide them to
Islam and they came with the same
mission same message one God worship
their God not his creation see the
fundamentals in a school will never
change what you are taught in the first
standard it develops in the 10th
standard what was taught to Adam Allah
Allah Adam or Islam Adam peace be upon
him the same fundamental remains with
more Muslim but the other ways of life
the way to practice them it developed
with the coming of Prophet Muhammad
sallallaahu thank you very much for at a
time
he's like Allah have you back and show
next time they got a mighty war thank
you very much alaikum Salam alaikum and
thank you for being with us here on the
Deen show we got to clear up some of the
confusion that person that is seeking
the truth all you got to do is want it
and then ask for it I can't guide you
the one who can guide you the one who
created you but you got to want the
guidance
seek it earnestly ask god almighty alone
to guide you and he will put you on the
straight path but you got to ask you got
to put all these other distractions on
hold put it to the side and realize that
there is a purpose in life there is
something that you need to be doing in
this life and who best to tell you than
one who created you there's a paradise
and there's a Hellfire we want to avoid
the Hellfire and we want
get to paradise so we want to prepare we
want to prepare for the day of judgment
and this is what all the messengers of
God they taught brought and they warned
the people they gave them the good news
and the glad tidings of paradise if you
do good and you pass the test in this
life so don't get caught by surprise
when death hits you be ready for that
moment and the best way to be ready is
by doing God's will by doing Islam we'll
see you next time until then peace be
unto you in every individual that comes
a day where they need to take a second
just to contemplate about line man the
one - why am i living it just breathe my
days decreasing God please see me give
me the reason why you brought me in this
life the truth I wanting the sometimes
you get so depressed I'm stressed no
control of my soul like a hole in my
chest can't sleep at night so what
rapper to the open watch the stores
while I listen to the ocean